what are you thinking you when you get
into a tank you think you're getting
into a place that no one can touch you
no one can bother you you're good to go
now I never had this feeling when I was
in the back of tank you did I definitely
didn't feel like oh I'm untouchable
because Bradley's were getting blown up
and destroyed and it was vicious to die
inside of a Bradley so I never felt any
level of comfort when I was getting into
a Bradley Fighting Vehicle to Transit
somewhere in ramadi why is that well
it's because I had seen Bradley's get
blown up and seen the damage that it
caused and seen the people get killed in
those so now the first day goes by and
all of a sudden you hear rumors right
wait wait they have some kind of
anti-tank weapons they're shooting or
tanks and it's destroying our tanks
killing the guys inside and they well
how many how many tanks got knocked out
and all of a sudden it's like seven
twelve 14 tanks